too many people when they think about a
platform especially the new hot thing
instagram seven years ago tick tock
right now they think how am i gonna make
something that's gonna get everybody
listen to my spotify i'm gonna get big
the way i think about [ __ ] is how i know
this is where every kid
15 30 is paying attention how am i gonna
watch this and figure out what everybody
likes
you've got your perspective
i just wanna be happy don't you wanna be
happy
[Music]
yo it's mike floyd i was on the other
side of that camera i'm gary's artist
relations person
now
this one's very special because we love
fresco trey we're working with fresco
trey as much as we can as organically as
we can we believe in him we know you're
gonna love him so you know after
watching this video if you're interested
if you're curious go watch his socials
go watch his youtube
go do anything you can spread the word
because that's how people like trey blow
up i really [ __ ] with your sound thank
you bro i really really do that's crazy
thank you i really do i listen to it a
lot
the [ __ ] song that you made for us is
crazy what's going on with that when's
the video
dude guys i love that song so i listen
that song
that so
our relationship's real interesting
because
like
you i don't tell you guys mike is in it
mike knows everybody coming up listens
to everything like
i really believe he's truly one of the
great a r people which is why because he
doesn't work out at label
i am good at just knowing what's going
to be big
whatever social media nfts
so with music
you know i often say things like the
best movie ever made the best song ever
made the best book ever written didn't
become the most popular because i
believe that i think the distribution of
something matters the moment in time one
little thing can change things but
when i when i tell you fresh off a
heartbreak when i listen to it i know it
can be the biggest song in america
whether it is or isn't is actually
irrelevant because there's been a lot of
songs that i felt that about that what
it means is that you can do it
got it it does i'm not it's irrelevant
if it goes or doesn't go it's that you
have it in you
and that's where i get excited i got a
newspaper i was trying to tell them
something you played for anyone here
they're going to like it that's
especially
who oh we have the b car uh i i may be
coming to you guys soon i have this at
my nft conference in minnesota may 20th
19 20 21 and
i had a whole day on monday
um look deciding on talent speakers
performing all that and you were on the
list because boyd knows i [ __ ] with you
and
you know and we were talking with big
names up and coming i'm talking to my
whole team about producing and the show
and i'm like
maybe we'll just do like a up-and-coming
set we're like because i was looking at
all the names and the rough prices we
thought for performance because mike was
doing his best guess or if he got the
answers from managers i was looking at
him it's like
and and i was talking so it was about
like eight people in this meeting and i
was like
yeah maybe i'll have fresco and tierra
and all this and and
i was like do you guys know for i was
flexing a little because i know they
wouldn't know i was like you guys know
fresco i was like listen to this and i
played it for them and they [ __ ]
loved it not kinda like a lot
that's fine that's heard because this
song was like one of the songs i was
like i went through my heartbreak and i
was like making all these sad songs like
i was like you know i need to make a
song about okay my heart was broke but
like i'm i'm i'm like kind of getting
over it like i'm fresh off with it so
that that song it was crazy because that
song i had made
we dropped the probably like a few weeks
later and he kind of like jumped over a
lot of other songs but because who's
like trying to get something out there
because
we needed to drop something but we
didn't want to drop
the project we was like planning we
wanted to put something out there for
the fans and like that song just like
did his things it was like crazy
it's a song that from a beat first of
all your sound
it's just everything's right about that
song it's honest
your sound and the beat and just like
it's just people underestimate
authenticity
and i believe
you're gonna have to prove me right i
just think that you have a sound that
will resonate with just a lot of people
there's certain people i listen to that
i really [ __ ] with but i'm like this is
gonna stay in this kind of lane
i might think you can cross over to a
much better market
how much do you pay attention to
tick-tock
are you personally the human being not
like as a professional but you the dude
recently i i've been
more penitent to it more than i had was
before before like i got all my
followers and stuff before i was just
trying to do stuff and it wasn't working
so i was just like you know what i don't
do tic toc but then i started getting
videos that went viral and stuff and now
like we pay more attention to it and i'm
just trying to like micromanage it but
like you know
it's really important for you like
really important
it's going to be the whole game for the
next five years
and even like don't even think about it
from a standpoint of what you're gonna
make to get pop off think about it as
consuming it
to get a sense of what people [ __ ] with
too many people when they think about a
platform especially the new hot thing
instagram seven years ago tick tock
right now they think how am i gonna make
something that's gonna get everybody
listen to my spotify i'm gonna get big
the way i think about [ __ ] is how i know
this is where every kid 15 to 30 is
paying attention how am i gonna watch
this and figure out what everybody likes
which then subconsciously might get into
my writing
you may see one video
on a tuesday night that just people went
crazy about you might not even take note
you might laugh you might think the
person's good looking you might think
whatever
and that might affect something you say
in two weeks that is the zeitgeist the
pulse of what everybody [ __ ]
with you see where i'm going i want you
to be in it because i want you to be in
it
because then it's going to reflect in
your output
that's fine because that's what happens
right because you're in it then you say
something that all of them that were in
it [ __ ] with and then that makes that go
you know that's a good [ __ ] mike [ __ ]
endless lately with the tick tock it's
cool
yeah we got him verified and everything
i'm aware originally we got there
jesus yes sir bro bro i really on some i
have to run so i just want to leave with
this
i really think you have a chance of
being very very very big
you just got to keep working it
keep
back to heartbreak you just need to keep
writing
or i don't know how you do it if you
write first whether but just keep
speaking truth whatever you're going
through
that was one thing i know you got to go
but there's one thing like i told my dad
when first started i was like if i do
make it in music i want to make it for
being like my actual self
i don't want to make it it's so much
more fun than you could just live
you come out and on some fake [ __ ] then
you got to keep up that facade
and you got to be like like the thing i
keep telling cool things like this kind
of music or athletes i'm like what's
corny now
is gonna be did you see what russell
westbrook wore last night into the
stadium
yeah well that [ __ ] got his ass
beat in 96 right but now it's fresh as
[ __ ] if you just say your actual truth
that [ __ ] will come around
exactly when we were growing up this
music you had to be hard and there was
nothing else nothing else
starter jackets combat boots timbos
[ __ ] baggy
if you're if you
lived in like a okay neighborhood but
you're like auntie live somewhere else
you may pretend you were from like
everything had to be how hard are you
right you could like visit your grandma
once and be like i'm from there right
yeah right right
now
the whole it's beautiful you could be
whatever your truth is your truth you
don't need to be from la you can be from
os you could be living like it's all
because authenticity is what wins
exactly all right let's get a photo and
get out of here youtube watcher what's
up it's garyvee first of all thank you
so much i hope you're doing super well
during these times uh i also want to ask
you please subscribe because my
commitment and exploration of youtube is
about to explode stories polls more
content more engagement more surprise
and delight this is the time to
subscribe i hope you consider it and i
hope i see you soon
you